- [Voiceover] Okay squad, listen up.
There's more than one way to
end a game of sports ball.
There's the walk off home run,
the sudden death goal,
the buzzer beater.
But, within the
adrenaline-addled psyche of
the American sports fan,
can any of them produce a heart attack
like a successful Hail Mary pass?
Don't answer that.
It's rhetorical.
Why are Hail Marys special?
Because they're unicorns.
Since 1975, there's only been 28 of them
in professional football.
Why?
Because they're almost
impossible to get right.
To complete a Hail Mary,
the pass needs to be long,
like thrown from midfield long with
little or no time remaining on the clock,
and you need to be losing,
and the pass must lead to a touchdown
that results in at least a
tie, but preferably a win.
That is a Hail Mary.
Most quarterbacks are
likelier to marry a supermodel
than to throw a successful
Hail Mary in their career.
Exhibit A, Tom Brady.
So, how did this play,
which practically requires
an act of God, come to pass?
See what I did there?
Easy.
With a prayer.
Hail Mary full of grace,
the Lord is with thee.
So it's December 28th, 1975.
50 yards from the end zone but
needing a touchdown to win,
Cowboys quarterback and devout Catholic,
Roger Staubach, whispers
a Hail Mary to himself.
Hail Mary full of grace,
the Lord is with thee.
And launches a desperation
pass to receiver Drew Pearson.
The Cowboys win and the Hail
Mary is christened forevermore.
Any questions?
Good, now go win me some ballgames.